I have seen gods fly I've seen men build
weapons that I couldn't even imagine
I've seen aliens drop from the sky yeah
but I have never seen anything like this
how much more ID
[Music]
we are home
[Music]
my son it is your time show me my
respective
you get to decide what kind of thing you
are going to be
don't freeze i never freeze
[Music]
damn
cuz we own
I waited my entire life for this the
world's gonna start over I'm a burn at
all what happens now determines what
happens to the rest of the world
[Music]
you
close your eyes
see with mine
[Music]
you are a top student but look at you
now you can't keep using your father's
disappearance as an excuse to act out is
that his work well what's it about their
dad he wanted to touch the Stars imagine
that the abbe here wants to get to her
other hand as quickest option is to walk
across the street but it turns out a
straight line is not the shortest
distance between two points not if you
use a fifth dimension it's outside of
the rules we know as time and space the
aunt arrives in my hand instantaneous so
you follow space more likely weren't
going
[Music]
we heard a cry out in the universe we
believe he is and we're here to help you
find it we are in search of warriors
warriors who serve the good and the
light of the universe you're kidding
do I look like I'm kidding a little I'm
not I'm not your father's trapped by
evil energy it's too strong for our
light and the only one who can stop it
is you be a warrior
my glove is always there even if you
can't see
[Music]
I trust you
[Music]
what's your name Laura surname Croft
Barra your father's gone you could pick
up where he left off I see so much of
him in you
brilliant hello sprout if you're
listening to this then I must be dead
I found something a tomb called the
mother of death if Trinity succeeds our
world is in danger promise me you will
stop I promise I think I know where my
dad went that's right in the middle of
the devil sea it won't be an adventure
death isn't a hundred an adventure
[Music]
[Music]
you shouldn't have come here but I'm
glad that you did
[Music]
what do you know about my father now I
see the lightness the recklessness close
the to once and for the fate of humanity
is now in your hands
[Music]
don't be too careful these days
the world has gone bloody mad I'll take
to the japanese archipelago' 20 years in
the future
canine saturation has reached epidemic
proportions an outbreak of dog flu
ripped through the city of Mecca sake
mayor Kobayashi issues emergency orders
calling for a hasty quarantine trash
island becomes an exiled colony the Isle
of Dogs I don't think I can stomach any
more of this garbage mouth nobody's
giving up around here and don't you
forget it ever your Rex your king your
Duke your boss I'm chief we're a pack of
scary indestructible alpha dogs Atari
Kobayashi
you heroically hijacked a junior
turboprop XJ 750 and flew it to the
islands because of the dog
darn it I've got a crush on you we get
the idea you were looking for your lost
dog spots
does anybody know sparks if he's alive
may very well be living even at this
moment as a captive prisoner somebody is
up to something will you help him the
little pilot why should I
because he's a 12 year old boy dogs love
those
we'll find him wherever he is if he's
alive we'll find your dog
it's gonna be a fight
[Music]
or somebody spoke his language
Wow to the north a long rickety causeway
over noxious sludge marsh leading to a
radioactive landfill polluted by toxic
chemical garbage that's our destination
right get ready to jump
[Music]
[Music]
we were born into a world at war between
the monsters that destroyed our cities
and the monsters we created to stop them
we thought we had sacrificed enough but
the wall we thought we finished is just
be it and the only thing standing in
front of the apocalypse
is us
but it doesn't matter where you came
from you believed in you and who didn't
this is our time this is our chance to
make a difference
let's get it done
from my ball
they evolve
piggies
there's something you need to see
well he's pretty big
[Music]
by everything you go diesel
delete all
I live here in Columbus Ohio in 2045 had
still ranked the fastest-growing city on
earth but it sure doesn't seem like it
when you live in the stacks
they called our generation than missing
millions missing not because we went
anywhere
there's no more left to go
nowhere except the Oasis
it's the only place that feels like I
mean anything
the world where the limits of reality
are your own imagination
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
dumb so you me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
I'm gonna ask you a series of questions
I want you to respond truthfully have
you ever heard someone yes have you ever
experienced anything you'd consider
ignore me
[Music]
yes last question do you know a mutants
are
did you know baby rattlesnakes are more
dangerous and adult ones they haven't
learned how to control how much venom
they secrete
[Applause]
all of you are dangerous
that's why you're here
[Music]
what is this place this is in hospital
that's a haunted house
[Applause]
[Music]
you're being through hard get some rest
[Music]
[Applause]
there was an idea to bring together a
group of remarkable people to see if we
could become something more so when they
needed us
we could fight the battles that they
never could
[Music]
in time you will know what it's like to
lose to feel so desperately that your
right yet to fail all the same
drive it
run summit destiny still alive
[Music]
evacuate the city
and gates or defenses
and get this man a sheet
[Music]
[Music]
long isn't something one considers
imbalance in the universe
but this
does put a smile on my face
[Music]
the hell are you guys
[Music]
[Music]
hello there welcome back I'm glad you
could join me today let's just dive
right in and run all the colors across
the screen that you'll need to paint
along with me I have my regular old
canvas here wet and ready to go now
let's grab our trusty two-inch brush
here whack that off a little bit just
beat it like it owes you money we're
gonna get a little damp or yellow snow
here mix that with just another little
dab of our baby white now well that's
just Daniel Sedin happy little say I
remember this is your world you get to
make and break the rules here sweet baby
Jesus
wish I could jump in there and roll
around and all that cascading white
powder yeah just get high and all of
life's splendor God I love cocaine so
much
holy [ __ ] knuckles I am high as a kite
right now okay
let's paint in a few little happy trees
there nothing wrong with making friends
with trees no what you don't want to do
is eat these paints trust me on this one
all right I'm gonna whack off from Ken
that's right that feels good
[Laughter]
would you look at that it seems like we
have ourselves a finished painting so
from our family to yours keep your pants
dry your dreams went and remember hugs
death drugs
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so uh what are you dating like an
accountant our Ellen ventriloquist stop
you love a dummy this is not where we
hear me I know I were here a rescue op
save the dinosaurs from the island
that's about to explode what could go
wrong blue is alive you raised her
do these animals deserve the same
protections given to other species or
should they just be left to die these
creatures were here before us and if
we're not careful
they're gonna be here after
you know me
[Music]
[Music]
life cannot be contained life breaks
free life finds away
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you